معنا مشاهدينا الان في الاستوديو كل من
ستاند اب كوميديا كوميديا
معنا محمد بدر وعلي الاسمر اهلا وسهلا
[ضحك]
على كل حال خليني ابدا معك محمد
مختلفه
لهجات عربيه مختلفه وكثير كثير من الاحيان
الكوميديا بتكون مرتبطه باللغه باللهجه
كيف قدرتوا توصلوا لكل الجمهور العربي على
اختلاف جنسياته بهذا التنوع يعني عايز
اصبح بس على بقيه الفريق موجود معنا
النهارده
انتم مش متفرغين للسنه متفرغ علي نص متفرغ
انا بشتغل يعني ممكن مدير ويكون بيسمعنا
ربنا يجعل كلامنا اليوم
متى
اجمد كوميديان في مصر ولبنان احنا دائما
لازم نعرف
عبد الله الانصاري اجمد كوميديان خليجي
اسلام مش عايز اقول بتاعه عشان هو بيستخدم
بتاعه في نكته
ايدي عملاق سوريا وايمان خلوف هجره
المانيا قريب نتمنى لها التوفيق
فقط
دلوقتي الناس كلها بتقول انه اللهجات همم
الله يرحمكم الله يا شيخ ههه
يعدي وقت المقابله واحنا ما سمعناش ولا
جواب واحنا بنقول انه
في دايما اختصر انه الفوني يكون بس عند
المصريين مثلا او الجمهور عارفين بالظبط
على الكوميديان العراقي فاحنا كنا عايزين
نقول انه الحاجه الوحيده اللي فعلا ممكن
تجمعنا احنا كعرب مع بعض هي النكته هي
الضحكه هي الموقف اللي ممكن يترجم باي
لهجه وما زال مضحك
ومن كده انت ممكن تلاقي مثلا علي يطلع
قدام ليله احنا ما نعرفش مين الجمهور ممكن
يكون اغلبيته مصري وبيسمع عليه ويضحك عليه
يطلع جمهور اغلبيته عراقي ويطلع كوميديان
خليني اسال احنا عندنا دقيقه راح نروح
للاخبار ونرجع مره ثانيه لكن علي يعني
المصريين مثل ما قال لك اصحاب نكته
بالاردني محمد انت اردني مش معروفين قصدي
بدر علي
الاول سؤال بنساله هذه الفتره اردنيه
بالضبط مش
ضحكنا اليوم خصوصا
الاردن في اصعب ناس ضحككم عن جد المصريين
بعرف لو لو ضحك من جمهور كله مصري خلص
معناته عن جد كنت بضحك يعني
اللهجه تبعتنا مش كثير متداوله عندهم
بس الكي بتكون انه استخدم كلمات تكون
معروفه للكل ما افوت كتير اردني واستخدم
كلمات بس الشعب الاردني هو اللي بيعرف
خلاص خلينا نروح اخبار ونرجع مره ثانيه
مش خايف خايف والله خايف
[ضحك]
طيب محمد بدر وعلي اسمر
[موسيقى]
طيب خليني اسال سؤال منهم الكوميديان ده
ياخذ موقف وبيبني عليه دوائر وحلقات متصله
انه حصل كذا الى اخره له اليوم احنا لما
نتكلم عن البرامج الصباحيه
البرامج الصباحيه
نظرتكم كيف
تنظروا لها ازاي
ما انتم بتضحكوا على زاويه سوده بتضحكوا
فيها
يلا
الكوميدي كيف ننظر لها انا كنت عم بحكي
لكم
الكوميديا
يعني انك تتعرض لازمات كبيره زائد وقت
فانت لما تشوف السكته تبعنا حتعرف انه كان
في مشاكل نفسيه متراكمه تحولت لمواقف
كوميديه هلا يعني تمرهم
لا ما احنا ههه اليوم احنا يمكن
بدر ما ادري
خليني اسد انه اليوم دائما الموقف الموقف
اللي تشوفه
ربما الضخمه هي كالكاريتين صح صح انت
موافقني شوف اي موقف بيصير يعني هاي
الموقف ممكن يكون موقف طبيعي بدر حكى عنه
لا يعني هذه هذه الفقره انا عطست فيها
وعمرها ما صارت معي على الهواء المايك
قاعد يا استاذ عادل اللعين فلقه الحجر
العيال اللي معانا في الفرقه مش بص لنا في
الفقره يا جدعان
لازم نجيبهم كلهم طب محمد انا كنت بدي
اسالك هل الكوميديا برايكم شيء
[ضحك]
الكوميديا برايكم انتم لانه عندكم حس
الفكاهه وبتشتغلوا حتى بالكوميديا هل هو
اشي بتورثوه هل اهاليكم مثلا دمهم خفيف
بنكتب
على ابنها بالظبط
عن الحاجات اللاينات اللي اديهولنا العيال
واحنا صغيرين يعني ممكن يبقى معاك في
المدرسه متنمر بس بيطلع منه لاينات حلوه
انا انا خلاني التنمر اتنمر على مرتي فصار
كل نكت على المتزوجوني التنمر هذا كوميديا
تنمريه خلينا نقول اذا هيك هذه كوميديا
لطيفه التنمر لطيف يعني يعني
طيب شو رايكم تتنمروا علينا
والله حلو بس انا يعني النقطه اللي انا
بقولها ان هو البرنامج الصباحي في قناه
العربيه بالظبط هو النقطه المضيئه الوحيده
في اليوم الصراحه هوبا ليه لان الاخبار
كلها حروب
يكسروا المايكات وبعدين عاده كان بيقفل
النشره زمان بفقره بتضحك
مش عارف ايه النهارده
جايين نكسر
طيب اتحولت في في العالم العربي
الكوميديان اصبح مهنه مش هوايه اليوم
في الولايات المتحده اصبحوا محترفين هنا
ما فيش صناعه كوميديا ما فيش صناعه ان انت
يبقى في قرش كتاب يعني هي بتبدا من كتابه
النكته حبكه اه من كتابه المسلسلات
الكوميدي ده اللي بيخلي الموضوع فيه صناعه
لان انت هيبقى في صناعه ناس تدخل يبقى
بتاخد فلوس بعدين الناس بتروح بالليل تجرب
النكت على ناس فيطلع الصبح يحطها في
سكريبت احنا لسه مثلا لغايه دلوقتي
المسلسلات الكوميدي بتكتبها واحد مش مش مش
زي زي امريكا فانت وكمان امريكا يعني هو
نموذج ظالم قوي لان امريكا قاره حجمها
كبير قوي فتخيل انت قاعد تقدر تتحرك من كل
الولايات دي ابعد ولايه لابعد ولايه 12
ساعه سفر
فانت تقدر تلف من الدنيا دي كلها واحنا
بنروح على ابو ظبي حالنا بنعمل تور يعني
محمد
محمد بدر بدر منور ان شاء الله دائما شكرا
جزيلا على اسمر
حبيبي شكرا جزيلا يعطيكم العافيه
ههه
هذه الفقره اللي نسياني يا شباب ههه
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات